there are always a lot of attendees at
big conventions but at one underway in
Japan this week only some of the
participants are human the city of Tokyo
is hosting the world robot summit and
it's packed with the usual assortment of
the practical the weird and the
entertaining lucy crafts got a look
inside when it comes to factory robots
japan is king more than half of all
industrial robots sold last year were
made in japan the hazardous behemoths of
old are getting kinder and gentler once
corralled behind fences factory bots are
now working side by side and even
collaborating with humans at unneeded
killer lifting 40 pound components is a
real strain on human bodies some robots
do the heavy lifting and people do the
light complex work explains this
developer modern robots have a light
enough touch to grab and delicately box
potato chips billed as the world's first
high-precision tactile robot arm this
device enables users to remotely sense
what's being touched even from 3,000
miles away technology that promises to
transform fields from agriculture to
medicine to disaster response Japan has
long had a love affair with robots and
with its own human population on the
decline it's no surprise that robots are
coming off the factory floor to play an
ever expanding role in everyday life
robots are being tested in the
notoriously short-handed nursing
industry and helping monks perform
funerals they're being mobilised as tour
guides
and as the ideal ping-pong partner plays
at any level never slams down its racket
Robo sniffer dogs keel over to warn
their users about food odor and this
pigtailed bot tells users if they pass
the smell test
oh you got this robot takes the
heartache out of halitosis explains its
developer even the banal chit chat
daytime TV has been creepily replicated
by this Android purely close to an
actual celebrity whatever shape they're
in
robots are grabbing attention like never
before for CBS this morning Saturday
Lucy craft Tokyo the big news there is
the robot with the rake exactly if we
could get one to shovel snow then I like
that partake of halitosis never [ __ ] oh
no but I can't stand the thought of them
taking all those jobs away oh well it's
so neat I know it's gonna be a big issue